Science proves that YouTube commenters are
just the worst.
They said it, not me!
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - with DEFINITIVE
PROOF that YouTube trolls exist, science has
proven it, officially - and it is out of my
hands!
A study published in PLOS One this week, conducted
an extensive analysis of TED Talks, to see
if comments on the YouTube version of them
differed from comments on the TED Talks website.
Now if you're unfamiliar with TED talks, they
are a collection of recorded conferences covering
every intellectual topic imaginable - but
always with a very inspiring slant.
And they're super informative, so one might
expect the comments on them to be on-topic
or, dare we say, even positive.
But once again, science has proven us wrong.
For their study, a team of researchers looked
at 595 different TED talks relating to science
and technology, which currently account for
around two-thirds of all TED talks.
And they looked at the comments on each video,
comparing those on the YouTube platform, to
ones on the Ted.com version.
They found that 72% of the comments on the
Ted.com videos were related to the actual
content of the talk - while only 57% of comments
on the YouTube version were relevant.
Even less surprising, 5.7% of the comments
on YouTube were personal insults, compared
to less than 1% on Ted.com.
The study also looked at the disparity of
comments on talks featuring female presenters,
versus ones featuring males.
And while there were no differences in the
number of negative or positive comments related
to the actual subject matter - female presenters
did tend to elicit more emotional responses
than males, whether positive and negative.
Perhaps most interesting, the study found
that commenters were significantly more likely
to discuss a female presenter's looks - than
they were for a male-hosted talk.
SAY IT ISN'T SO, YOUTUBE!
In fact, the only advantage YouTube had over
Ted.com - was that people were more likely
to engage with one another in the comments.
And it's not clear whether personal insults
actually count as "engagement," but at this
point - nothing would surprise me.
Now I thought this study was very interesting,
so I did some research myself - and looked
at all 984 comments on this YouTube video
about the science of flirting - a topic that's
sure to attract only the nicest and most socially
capable of individuals.
Turns out - it's scientifically impossible
to read through 984 comments on a YouTube
video - it just can't be done.
So my study was inconclusive, BUT on the bright
side - several people did say that I look
like a man, soooo......there's that.
You know what, I'm gonna start an anti-trolling
movement.
The next time you leave a comment on YouTube,
I want you to write the kindest, most overwhelmingly
positive thing you can think of.
Even if it's not true.
And you can start with this video.
Please.
I really need this.